you get residuals off wild boys no
no God that's so [__] crazy dude that
is crazy yeah I don't get uh I don't get
anything when jackass was put to
streaming were they telling you the
numbers on what it was getting now
Paramount plus didn't exist when we did
our deals for the jackass movie and so
it wasn't built into our contracts that
they could put it on Paramount plus and
then when the movie came out they did
not take it to Netflix to get an idea of
its market value they just sold it to
themselves and they gave themselves a
pretty good deal yeah yeah so we got
kind of kind of screwed out of that
wasn't that what they're striking for
maybe this is why I should be supportive
of the strike because I don't feel like
I was ever particularly looked out for
by the right you didn't get residuals
from the jackass TV show right and you
got [__] on jackass forever